こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
はいというわけで
動画のタイトルにもある通り
わたくしはじめしゃちょー
アメリカに
3年間留学に行ってきます
えーとまず言わなきゃいけないことが
言うのがとても
遅くなってそして
急になってしまい
とても申し訳ないです
実はですね
結構ぎりぎりで
もうアメリカに行く寸前ぐらいです。今。
えっと、大変言うのが遅くなって申し訳なかったです
こうやっぱね、パッと言いたかったんすよ急に
僕らしくね
多分僕のこの
アメリカ留学のこと知ってる人は
めちゃくちゃ少ないです
あのホントに
身内の友達とかにしか言ってないんで
YouTuberでも知ってる人はほぼいないぐらいじゃないのかな
あのホントに急になって申し訳ないです
まあ3年間ほどアメリカに留学に行くわけなんですけども
えーと、2つ
目的があります
1つは
英語力のUP
半年くらいですね、大学生の時に
イギリスに留学してたんですけども
半年だとねやっぱ
英語を聴くのはよくなったんですけど
話すのがやっぱあんまり
変わんなくて
で、まあ今回3年間みっちりとね
ちゃんと英語勉強して
英語しっかり喋れるようになって
帰ってきたいと思っております
2つめが
まぁ僕の将来のことなんですけど
映像関係の勉強をしたいと
思っておりまして
アメリカのそういった学校の方に
3年間行く予定です
まあ今
YouTubeをしてるわけなんですけども
正直ちょっと
うん
もっと色んなことできるんじゃないかと思ってて
YouTubeでね
YouTube以外でもだ
YouTube以外でもなんですけども
僕は今後映像系のことをやっていきたいと思っているので
まあ自分のスキルアップのためにもね
アメリカに行って
映像技術の最先端を
学んできたいなと思っております
大学卒業してからほんとはすぐ行きたかったんですよ
アメリカに
まあけどちょっとこう色々ね
忙しかったりして
予定がかさばってて
あの今のタイミングになっちゃたんですけども
かなり前から行こうとは思ってました、アメリカ
Twitterでもちょいちょい言ってたんで多分
わかる人にはわかると思うんですけど
僕の中では
大きな
夢の一つです
正直今の生活もすごいいいんですよ
この日本での生活
毎日結構忙しいんですけど
それでも
楽しく
YouTubeをやってて
正直もう
文句言うところがないぐらい
今すごい幸せな生活をしていると思っているんですけど、
やっぱ現状で満足しちゃうと
そこでもう終わりだと思ったんで
今を見るより
未来のことを見据えてね
僕は今後行動してみたいなと思ってるんで
今後僕がもっと
大きな
男になる為には
このタイミングで
アメリカに3年間行くべきだなって僕は思いました
何言えばいいかわかんないんだよなー
こういう感じの時
何言えばいいんだろう
まぁ、ひとまず、ほんとに急になったのは
とても、申し訳なかったです。
であとこの家なんですけども、
まぁアメリカに3年間行くって言っても
そんなねぇ、ずっと向こうにいる感じじゃあないんですよ
まぁ3年間ずっとアメリカにいるというより、こう
ちまちまけっこう日本に帰ってくるので、
そうしたときに泊まる場所が、
また、てんてんとしちゃうんで、
まあこの家は借りたままで、
日本に帰ってきたときにまた普通に泊まります。
そんな感じかな。
まぁ、イギリスの留学中に分かったんですけど、
なんか留学中って時間が止まった感じに、感じるんですよ　僕は
なんで僕はイギリスで半年間留学してた時に
すごいいろんなことを考える機会になれたんですよ
ま、そこでね、こういろいろ考えたり
今後どうしようって考えた結果、
まぁYouTuberになろうっていう
決断ができたってところもあって、
ま、イギリスのあの半年間の留学がなかったら
ま、今のはじめしゃちょーいなかったです
留学とかね海外で長い期間過ごしたりね
修行っていうのかな
わかんないんですけど
そういう期間ですごい人生の中では大事な期間だと思っているんで
僕はアメリカでの３年間を無駄にはしたくないと思っております
まぁー投稿頻度、毎日とはいかないかもしれませんが
頑張って動画を更新しようと思ってますんで
はじめしゃちょーアメリカ編のスタートです
やっぱ俺は
なんかこんなかっこいいこと言いたくないんですけど
俺は日本だけでとどまるつもりはないんで
もっともっと上を目指して
現状に満足せず
もっとすごいことやってみたいなと思ってます
あっ、そうだあの
僕のこのアメリカ留学を相談していた身内の友達から
なんかさっきサプライズで動画が届いたんで
ちょっと見てみましょう
あーとー、、
めんちゃん
えー、大学卒業する時ぐらいから
ずっとアメリカに行きたいっていうのは話聞いてて
まぁー友人としてはほんとに３年間の留学だね、、
うれしいです、実際
でも、やっぱり、身近な
まぁ友達として僕は思っているんで
ほんとに、、
なんていうか
３年間めんちゃんが日本にいないっていうのがちょっと悲しいです
でも、やっぱりこう日本で今こんだけ活躍して
海外に行ってまた海外で日本以上に活躍してくれたなっていう
まぁすごいことを期待してます
ほんとにちょっとさみしいけど頑張ってきてください
海外でも大暴れしてくれると、僕はほんとにうれしいです
じゃーめんちゃん、、いってらっしゃい
ピコーン
えっと、はじめさん、３年間ロスで英語と映像の勉強するということで
アメリカに行ってしまうのは、とてもさびしいです
まーえっと僕が大学１年の時からなんでもう今年で５年目になって
ずっと一緒に動画をやって
いろいろ遊びに行ったりとかもたくさんしてたんで
まー３年間すごい離れてしまってなかなか会えない
ていうかほぼ会えなくなってしまうと思うので
とても寂しいです
はい
ほんとにまぁー、ロスでいろいろいっぱい勉強してきて
で、まー帰ってきたときにぜひもっともっと
クオリティーの高い動画を作ったり
まぁー世界で活躍できるYouTuberになってほしいなと
思います
ありがとう
３年間ほんとに頑張ってください
はい
たくみじゃん
すまん、はじめ久しぶり
３月のスキー以来、いや、スノボ以来かな
ごめん今日風邪ひいててさ、このタイミングで
まじか、、
ちょっと声は変だし
たんは出るし、せきは出るし、よくわかんない状況だし
顔も若いし、いつも通りなんだけど
今日ははじめに
昨日行くっていう決意を聞いたので応援のメッセージを撮ることにしました
ありがとう
自分が卒業するときに、はじめは、自分にメッセージをくれたから
今日ははじめに一言でメッセージを伝えたいと思います
距離は遠いけど応援してます
で、帰ってきたらまた遊びましょう
じゃーな！
ありがとう
友達との別れとかもつらいんですけども
まー、僕は悲しみより正直今後の楽しみのほうが大きいです
もっともっと大きくなって
胸を張って
日本に帰ってこれる日を
楽しみにしています
じゃーな！！